es fácil ver por qué Edward Teach y sus compañeros piratas
podrían ser vistos como pioneros del diseño moderno de comunicaciones,
y de por qué su símbolo letal,
(Risas)
hay más...
por qué su símbolo letal del par de tibias y la calavera
fue un precursor de los logotipos de hoy en día,
más bien como las grandes letras rojas de pie detrás de mí,
pero, por supuesto, con un mensaje diferente.
(Risas)
Sin embargo, el diseño también se usó para fines más nobles
por una diseñadora igualmente brillante e igualmente improbable,
la enfermera británica del siglo XIX, Florence Nightingale.
Su misión era brindar asistencia sanitaria decente a todos.
Nightingale nació en una familia británica muy bien situada y muy rica,
horrorizada cuando se ofreció voluntaria para trabajar en hospitales militares
durante la Guerra de Crimea.
Una vez allí, se dio cuenta rápidamente
de que más pacientes morían más por infecciones que se contagiaban allí,
en las salas sucias, fétidas,
que por las heridas de guerra.
Así que ella hizo campaña para que se construyeran
clínicas más limpias, claras y aireadas.
De regreso en Gran Bretaña,
condujo otra campaña,
esta vez para los hospitales civiles,
e insistió para que se aplicaran los mismos principios de diseño.
El pabellón de Nightingale, como se denomina,
dominó el diseño de los hospitales en las siguientes décadas,
y los elementos que aún hoy se usan.
Pero en ese entonces,
el diseño se veía como una herramienta de la era industrial.
Se formalizó y profesionalizó,
pero se limitó a funciones específicas
y generalmente en busca de objetivos comerciales
en vez de usarse de manera intuitiva,
como Florence Nightingale, Barbanegra y Ying Zheng lo habían hecho.
En el siglo XX,
este espíritu comercial era tan poderoso,
que cualquier diseñador que se desviaban de él
corría el riesgo de ser visto como raro o subversivo.
Entre ellos se encuentra uno de mis grandes héroes del diseño,
el brillante László Moholy-Nagy.
Fue el artista y diseñador húngaro
cuyos experimentos con el impacto de la tecnología en la vida diaria
fueron tan poderosos
que todavía hoy influyen en el diseño de las imágenes digitales
que vemos en nuestras pantallas de teléfono y computadora.
Él radicalizó la escuela de diseño Bauhaus en 1920, en Alemania,
y sin embargo, algunos de sus antiguos compañeros le evitaban
cuando quiso abrir una nueva Bauhaus en Chicago años más tarde.
Las ideas de Moholy eran tan audaces e incisivas como siempre,
pero su enfoque para el diseño era demasiado experimental,
como su insistencia en verlo, como él mismo dijo,
como una actitud, no como una profesión para estar en sintonía con los tiempos.
Y, por desgracia, lo mismo se aplica
a otro inconformista del diseño: Richard Buckminster Fuller.
Otro diseñador visionario brillante
y activista del diseño,
completamente comprometido con el diseño de una sociedad sostenible,
con visión tal de futuro
que empezó a hablar de la importancia del ambientalismo
en el diseño de la década de 1920.
A pesar de sus esfuerzos,
muchos diseñadores establecidos le tildaban rutinariamente de raro
y, es cierto,
algunos de sus experimentos fallaron,
como el auto volador, que nunca llegó a despegar.
Y, sin embargo, la cúpula geodésica,
su fórmula de diseño para construir un refugio de emergencia
con desechos de madera, metal, plástico,
trozos de árbol, mantas viejas, láminas de plástico,
con casi todo lo disponible en el momento,
es una de las mayores hazañas del diseño humanitario,
y ha dado el refugio tan necesario
a muchas, muchas personas en circunstancias desesperadas
desde entonces.
Fue el valor y el entusiasmo de diseñadores radicales
como Bucky y Moholy
que me llevó a diseñar.
Empecé mi carrera como periodista y corresponsal de prensa extranjera.
Escribo sobre política, economía y asuntos corporativos,
y podría haber elegido especializarme en cualquiera de esos campos.
Pero elegí el diseño porque creo
que es una de las herramientas más poderosas a nuestra disposición
para mejorar nuestra calidad de vida.
Gracias compañeros aficionados al diseño de TED.
(Aplausos)
Y mucho admiro también los logros de los diseñadores profesionales,
que han sido extraordinarios e inmensos.
También creo
que el diseño se beneficia enormemente de la originalidad,
el pensamiento lateral
y el ingenio de sus rebeldes y renegados.
Y estamos viviendo en un momento notable en el diseño,
porque este es un momento donde ambos campos están cada vez más cerca.
Porque incluso los avances muy básicos de la tecnología digital
les han permitido operar de manera autónoma
dentro o fuera de un contexto comercial,
para alcanzar objetivos cada vez más ambiciosos y eclécticos.
Por lo tanto, en teoría,
plataformas básicas como el crowdfunding, computación en la nube, medios sociales,
dan mayor libertad a los diseñadores profesionales
y ofrecen más recursos para los improvisados
y, con suerte,
una respuesta más receptiva a sus ideas.
Algunos de mis ejemplos favoritos están en África,
donde una nueva generación de diseñadores
está desarrollando tecnologías increíbles en la Internet de las Cosas
para cumplir el sueño de mejorar la salud de Florence Nightingale.
En los países donde más personas ahora tienen acceso a teléfonos móviles
que a agua corriente y potable.
Y entre ellos es Arthur Zang.
Él es un ingeniero de diseño joven de Camerún
que ha convertido una tablet en el Cardiopad,
un dispositivo de vigilancia cardíaca en móvil.
Se usa para monitorear el corazón de pacientes en zonas rurales remotas.
Los datos se envían entonces a una red celular
a hospitales bien equipados, a cientos de km de distancia
para el análisis.
Y si hay algún problema son vistos por los especialistas allí,
Se recomienda un curso adecuado de tratamiento.
Y esto, por supuesto, ahorra a muchos pacientes
hacer viajes largos, arduos, costosos y a menudo inútiles
a los hospitales.
Y hace que sea mucho, mucho más probable
que realmente se exploren sus corazones.
Arthur Zang empezó a trabajar en el Cardiopad hace ocho años,
en su último año en la universidad.
Pero no logró convencer a fuentes convencionales
de que invirtieran para poner en marcha el proyecto.
Él publicó la idea en Facebook,
donde un funcionario del gobierno camerunés lo vio
y logró obtener una subvención del gobierno para él.
Ahora está desarrollando no solo el Cardiopad,
sino otros dispositivos médicos móviles para el tratar diferentes enfermedades.
Y él no está solo,
hay otros muchos diseñadores emprendedores con inspiración
que también llevan a cabo proyectos extraordinarios solos.
Y terminaré mostrando solo algunos de ellos.
Uno es Peek Vision.
Se trata de un grupo de médicos y diseñadores en Kenia,
que han desarrollado una Internet de las cosas por su propia cuenta,
como un kit portátil de examen de los ojos.
Luego está Gabriel Maher,
que está desarrollando un nuevo lenguaje de diseño
que nos permita articular sutilezas de las identidades cambiantes de género,
sin recurrir a los estereotipos tradicionales.
Todos estos y muchos diseñadores más están realizando sus sueños,
sacando lo mejor de su nueva libertad,
con la disciplina de los diseñadores profesionales
y el ingenio de los rebeldes y renegados.
Y todos nos beneficiaremos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)